Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today is an episode of Rawkode Live where
we're taking a look at a tool to
simplify
your Kubernetes experience.
That tool is called kpt.
Now, of course, I am not smart enough
to get us through learning all these new
tools. We're gonna reach out to people with
all of the knowledge, and I have the
pleasure today of being joined,
ta da,
by Brian and Justin, both engineers at Google
who work and drive the kpt project forward.
Hello. How is it going?
Hello.
Alright. So thank you both for joining me
today. And for anyone that's not, familiar with
you, doesn't follow you on Twitter or LinkedIn
or anything like that, can you both just
say hello and tell us a little bit
about yourselves? And, we'll just start with you
in the middle there, Justin.
Hi. I'm Justin Santa Barbara. I am a
software engineer at, Google.
I have been working on the Kubernetes project
more or less since the beginning, not quite
as long as Brian,
but,
for, like, since at least before one point
o.
And,
now work at Google on a team trying
to help users,
make more and better use of Kubernetes.
And part of that is the project we're
gonna be looking at today. And
the team I work on is also responsible
for customize
and config sync and config connector and config
controller, so a bunch of those sort of
tools around Kubernetes and expanding it to to
new areas.
Alright. Thank you.
Hi. I'm Brian Grant. I was part of
the original team that created Kubernetes at Google.
I was the API design lead and lead
architect.
Been working on configuration
for Kubernetes for a long time. Keep control
apply,
customize
our
tools I created and also kept as
kind of the latest
iteration on that.
A little bit of a twist on
customized approach.
Alright. Thank you both for sharing.
Before we talk about what kpt is then,
maybe we can just because you've both already
mentioned a couple of other Kubernetes tools. Like,
we're definitely in the Kubernetes ecosystem spoiled for
choice, and I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing. But there
are a lot of tools
to help us deploy to Kubernetes.
Why do you think that is?
Why do we Spreadsheet
of more than a hundred tools.
Yeah. And configuration
is
is a hard problem.
It's a user interface surface.
So,
you know, it really dominates how people experience
using Kubernetes.
And
therefore, a lot of preferences
become involved
in how
configuration is actually authored and modified.
You know? So people may start simple with
just plain YAML.
And at some point when that becomes
too hard to maintain, they will switch to
a different tool. Some people will
build their own tool. You know, you could
just use m subs or sed, for example,
to replace some parts of the configuration.
That's pretty easy. This is one reason why
there are so many tools is because
with the way the Kubernetes API is designed
to be natively declarative,
all you need to do is create a
way to basically render
the
resource
definitions
for Kubernetes, and you can do that any
way you want. And then you can just
apply them,
and you're off to the races. Right? So
it's not nearly
as hard to build a tool as it
is, you know, for cloud configuration, for instance,
where,
a lot more,
orchestration and
API calls and trans transformation and those kinds
of things are are necessary.
For the most part,
just
rendering the configuration, applying it, and let the
controllers figure it out just works,
which is
opens up a lot of different
possibilities
for how that configuration is actually generated.
Yeah. It feels like a lot of the
the tooling that we have in this in
this space is they're they're all different versions
of of of templating tools because we have
to be able to build up a lot
of YAML when working
with Kubernetes.
And I think yeah.
What a hundred, I didn't quite think it
was as high as that, but I'm not
that surprised that there's that many tools. It
just seems to be that, you know, every
week, every other week on, you know, hacker
news or something like that, there's always this
new open source project that's gonna change the
way that we deploy to Kubernetes. It's gonna
simplify
something, which I it's already kinda simple, you
know, it's still templating. But for some reason,
we're deploying more and more things to Kubernetes.
Things are getting harder.
So I'm really curious to see and hoping
that when we take a look at kpt,
we can see something that's a bit different
because from my naive perspective here and what
I've seen on the documentation and what you
talked about on Twitter and what I've seen
on the GitHub is that kpt is different
to these other tools that we have, but
at least we've seen in this ecosystem. So
maybe now we could talk about what kpt
is and why it's different from these other
tools.
Yeah. I can talk. So the other tools
I consider,
what I call generators.
They generate configuration like you said. Right? So
templates is one category or configuration languages like
HCL or Q or
DAL or, you know, JSON or something like
that,
or general purpose languages like Hulumi or CDK.
But,
you know, in all of those cases, you
basically write
the entire configuration in
code or code like format or template format
and generate the entire thing. Now customize took
a different approach. It took a transformation based
approach where
it took some configuration as inputs and transformed
it in various ways through
built in transformers,
like to add labels or to add annotations
or to patch
the the resources, the so called overlay
approach. Now since then, a number of tools
have added support for overrides because overrides
are effectively,
you know, one of the most common patterns
that people need to do on top of
a
a base configuration or off the shelf configuration.
And that way, you don't have to template
the entire thing for every possible thing someone
might want to actually change. Instead, you can
just override it, so called last mile
configuration.
So other tools support that now too, but,
typically, they do generation first and then transformation
or override
in some way. So kpt's approach
is different in that it completely decouples
how the configuration is authored
from the transformations.
So since
Kubernetes
is natively declarative,
we're
leveraging that by saying, look. You can generate
the configuration however you want. You can write
it by hand using your favorite editor or
IDE,
or you can generate it with a tool,
or you can generate it with the UI.
It doesn't it shouldn't actually matter. And then
we can take that and transform it in
various ways, not just on the fly when
we're deploying it,
but in advance.
So
I think a lot of the toil and
and manual effort around configuration management
is overlooked. We're kind of desensitized to it.
We expect to have to
check out files from GET,
edit them,
commit, tag, push,
do a code review,
etcetera, before we can deploy anything.
And GitOps
makes that last deploy step more reliable and
and easier,
but it's really just that last step that
it's automating. And all that process before that
point, it's still a lot of work. And
with customize,
you know, customize can simplify the base configurations,
but the rest of the process is still
basically the same.
It's not any less work to,
you know, check out the files from gits,
edit them, commits,
push tag review,
render,
etcetera.
So
what we're doing with kpt is extending the
set of automation that we can apply to
that
whole space
to really cover the full life cycle of
the configuration.
And that
what we're doing is we're extracting the configuration
from storage,
transforming it, and writing it back.
And
I think the best way to really understand
this is to actually go through the process
and show it,
is what we found. So
so I'm actually looking forward to do that
to see what you think about it because
it's,
in some in some ways, very familiar
to things people are used to
and in other ways, radically different.
So different people have
different impressions about
what's actually going on and what the tool
can do and how it can change
how we manage configuration.
Alright. Yeah. I I'll start on go. Can
I, like, I also we like, we really
wanna hear what you think of it because,
I mean, I think you said something very
interesting, which is, you said,
like, there comes a point where you like,
where the complexity of YAML editing gets becomes
too much,
and you have to switch to generation or
templating or whatever it might be? And I
think what we're saying here is we are
producing something that
lets you take an alternate path. So we
can avoid all those, like, hundreds of different
templating solutions. Here's an alternate path. Hopefully, you
don't hit that decision point where you're like,
oh, I have to, like, abandon pure YAML.
Let's let's make the Kubernetes objects centric to
this and
give you what is going to be a
delightful experience, and your feedback as to how
delightful it is right now is gonna be
very interesting.
But, hopefully, you'll you'll see what we're what
we're trying to do even if it's even
if it could be more delightful in the
future.
Alright. Awesome. And we're we're gonna get to
the hands on component in just a moment,
but I I wanna
I always like to try and take what
people have told me and see if I
can spell it back in a way that
still could have makes sense, and we kinda
covered a lot there.
And I it's complete
transparency. I had never used kpt before. I
don't know what we're gonna see today. So
I'm I have we're coming into this with
open minds and looking to be excited. But
what you said was, as you
use whatever tools you want
to write your Kubernetes Java, like, kept is
not trying to hook in at that point
or replace that point. That's correct. Right?
It is. We we are gonna go
through
a process where kpt is providing a tool
to author the YAML. Alright. Okay. It doesn't
have to be it doesn't have to be
the only way.
The point of the
what we're gonna show with in through the
backstage UI plug in
is one possible
way that you
can author not just configuration, but actually configuration
blueprints
because that's a capability that's not really possible
with any of these hundred other tools.
Okay. You also said that kpt will pull
from storage, do transformations,
write back.
I'm curious. Does kpt apply to our cluster
or is it writing back to storage? And
is that storage could that be get or
are we talking about OCIR effects or something
else there? Like, maybe elaborate on that. So
both both actually. So what we have
in the tutorial right now, rights to git.
We're also have
OCI storage underway
being implemented.
Kept is
multiple components.
So one of those components is a GitOps
engine, a GitOps controller Okay. That can deploy
for you, but you can use RRBCD, Flex,
whatever your favorite
way of deploying to Kubernetes is.
Okay.
And the last question before we dive into
the thing. You mentioned
Backstage,
which I think is the UI component. The
homepage that we're gonna take a look at
let's take a look at. Like, the first
paragraph, it talks about WYSIWYG.
So is this something that you think is
the way we should be offering
manifest? Do you think, like, we should be
making this simpler and providing UIs and abstractions
to make this easier, or is that just,
like, a fun experiment? Like, what are your
thoughts around that? I mean, it is a
proof of concept, but I actually do think
UI
is
a way to
simplify
configuring
Kubernetes for a much broader audience
of folks. It doesn't just have to be,
you know, people who do hard code code
hardcore code development necessarily.
The
you know, I I heard that the GitOpsCon
North America last year,
you know, even folks using Argo CD who
are pretty familiar with it were say saying,
look,
we would really like to have
a UI on I mean, Argo CD has
a UI, but really
for deployment, if you configure an application,
through Argo CD, it doesn't write that back
to Git.
It just, you know, is a lot resource
in your cluster. Right? So how do you
actually take that experience and
enable writing that back to get?
The
most
automation tools, UIs,
command line tools,
etcetera, they operate against
APIs.
Right? That's how the that's how the tools
work. And
there's a long history of,
kind of a rich ecosystem of different kinds
of tools that can operate against APIs.
When we say, no. You can't actually call
those APIs. You have to write
code,
templates, text files, check them in to get
go through all these manual process
to then finally deploy them. What we've
walled off
those APIs from automation of all different kinds.
And,
you know, that's considered if you have, say,
a security
remediation
function that says,
you know, you can't have any pods that
run as privileged, for example.
You can do that on the fly using
an image controller in Kubernetes
to make that change.
But what if you don't want any of
your con configuration
your applications in the source of truth to
be configured to use privileged pods? How do
you check that? Like, what if you do
have a home chart, say,
that tries to deploy an application
that, you know, has privilege or something like
that? How do you actually go find that
and fix that? That's actually
really challenging. So
what we're what kpt can do is it
can actually make the configuration
modifiable
and readable
again through APIs.
You know, it basically can provide a control
plane and a data plane for manipulating
configuration.
So that
you know, in terms of the UI, the
UX there are lots of UX techniques for
mitigating domain complexity and simplifying things.
And we're just, you know, at the early
stages right now and definitely can be made
more delightful in the future, as Justin said.
But
I think we've only really just scratched the
surface of what we can do
with that kind of an approach
where we can simplify but not abstract.
Okay.
Alright. Well, I am ready to be deleted.
And the reason I brought up the UI
there is, you know,
it's really easy for developers to say, oh,
I just spend all my entire life in
the terminal, and I just type, you know,
white text on a black background or green
text on a black background. But I think
there's been a shift lately. And you mentioned
the Argo CD UI and Flux is building
the UI too. There's that when
we're working with these complicated systems, the UI
is actually a really strong value add because
it's nice
be able to step away from the YAML
for just even a minute. But I I
love that also we're seeing, you know, lens
and all these other I can't remember the
name of other GUIs. I feel really bad.
They're all awesome. But we're seeing a lot
of GUIs pop up for Kubernetes as well
where you don't even need to run control
commands anymore. Like, you just get this wonderful
interface that says here's all the pods, here's
the ones that are failing, here's all the
logs. Like, yeah, that simplification
that the UI can bring, I think, is
a really exciting thing. So I'm I'm Yeah.
A a UI can provide
discovery for people who are new. You know,
it can take
concerns away from you. Like, you don't have
to think about how to format the YAML,
how how many spaces you need to indent
certain fields, things like that.
It can help you navigate across related
resources or
auto completes when filling things out.
It can give you step by step guidance
and walk you through the process.
So there are really a lot of ways
that
a UI can help.
And,
you know, just because the tool is used
by developers doesn't mean that, you know, there
aren't cases where people could use that help.
Like, if you're using a configuration
generation tool, whether it's, you know, CDKed S
or Helm or whatnot.
You know, you can edit a few parameters
maybe in the ideal case
and run the tool to generate the configuration.
That part is
often straightforward. But how do you actually create
the template in the first place?
That is still all manual.
It's still all done from scratch, and you
have the problems not just with, you know,
how to indent the YAML, but
how to actually
cause the YAML to get generated in the
right way
such that it will be valid and so
on. So
yeah. So, anyway, I'm hoping that
the experience will be
a little bit of a a shift in
in how we can think about, you know,
what's possible in this space.
Alright. I think on that note, we are
ready to jump straight into this and start
playing then. Yeah. We should start installing stuff.
Otherwise, we'll run out of time.
Well, we don't want that. Alright. Let's get
my being shared. So we do have the
homepage here. If anyone wants to check it
out, it's kpt.dev.
Yep. Cool. Just make sure I didn't get
that wrong. I have a Kubernetes cluster. I
haven't prepared anything upfront today except for just
filling up a cluster that we can play
around with.
And if we come back to here and
skip over the video for now, we get
to the installation instructions instructions as well as
a book, an entire book, which is awesome.
It's always I don't know. I I play
with a lot of very new open source
projects and the documentation can sometimes be lacking.
So I love it when I find a
project and it's already started to put on
that path or purchase it more
longer form consumable content. I really appreciate that.
So let's get the CLI installed.
It says here on install, we've got the
CLI, the package orchestrator,
config sync, and the the UI. Are we
gonna install all of these today?
Yeah. Okay. Cool.
So
let me just click that.
Get the executable
and we'll move it to somewhere handy so
I don't need to type too much.
Permissions.
The last time I did this, my
sudo crashed, and I ended up typing my
password on the terminal. That was fun.
Okay. That's good enough. And no version of
like, but we do have we do have
kept. Just say kept version, I think.
There
we go. Yeah. There you go.
Alright. So let's jump back. I don't need
to see if there's anything else. Do we
need all complete?
Is that just Nah. Nah. Alright.
So we're gonna install the park package orchestrator,
which is called Porch.
Let's see.
I need to deploy something to Kubernetes for
this. Is that what it's saying?
Yeah. You do.
Go ahead, Brian.
Oh, no. Go ahead. You you were just
ran through this this morning to make sure
it works. So
Yes. It's a it's a
it's a Port is actually a both CRDs
and, an aggregate API server. So it's sort
of technically very interesting, and it will be
very interesting to see. I have not tried
it on
Civo or Kivo,
so it will be a a scary moment
in a second.
But yes.
Alright. I just need to download
this.
That should be alright.
Forgetting her to computer.
Oh, it didn't download. Right.
I do I probably need to
I'm gonna just make sure this path works
because that's what my command says.
And of course I missed the layer.
Alright.
Cool.
I never thought downloading a file would be
my downfall today. We'll get there.
GitHub does not make it the easiest, at
least when I release this. It's
could be improved.
I should try some of the other ways
of distribution.
Alright. Well, we have a bunch of Kubernetes
YAML.
We're just gonna apply that all to the
cluster, and we're gonna wait until our porch
server is available.
Maybe while we wait for that, can someone
tell me what parch is? What what part
of the
kpt does this provide? What does it do?
What's its responsibility?
Porch is is short for a package orchestrator
or package orchestration.
And the idea is that it basically puts
the kept functionality
onto a server
so that you can
embed what would otherwise be CLI functionality into
other components.
So, for example, when you wanna build a
UI, it can be hard to have a
CLI as a back end for a web
server. And so porch is that,
back end,
but the intent is that it is, sort
of the same functionality as we're building in
the command line kept,
and you can choose to use the command
line or the server as appropriate. So probably,
you know, a lot of people will get
started using the command line. And,
when they want teams
or collaboration or things like that, they will
likely start using Torch as well.
Alright. Yeah. I mean, again, I think people
are desensitized to how much work it is
to
create a package from scratch.
Just as one example thing that porch can
do, you can create a package from scratch,
you can add resources to it,
you can modify packages and create new revisions
of them
all through the API.
Okay. Have I broken something there?
Unexpected
r kptrl
apply. Have I forgotten how to kptrl?
Yeah.
Dash f is not glob friendly in Kubernetes
in KubeCon.
Oh, but Michelle can expand that for me.
Oh, no.
And this is why we can turn them
into a No. I'm just being I'm being
really silly. Really, really silly. Just
do the directory. Yeah.
It's been a while.
Skill holidays. Bridge ride. That's driving me crazy.
So That kube control issue is probably still
open.
And it
because it's probably a four digit issue.
I suppose you don't know the number, Brian.
You normally know all the numbers.
Yeah. I gave up on that one. So
Alright. Well, we've deployed
porch.
We've deployed config sync, which I assume is
the the GetUp
operator sales thing.
And the last thing we're going to do
now is deploy the UI. So it wants
me to create a namespace,
which I'm happy to do.
The the original the number for the original
kptrol issue is 17 o two.
I'm pretty sure. Yeah.
So
Alright.
I guess you two have been working just
while that's deployed, working on Kubernetes long enough.
Who which one do you want to take
responsibility for it being kubectl
get deployments and not kubectl deployments get? Like,
was there was there a bit of a
fight over that at the time, or are
you or was that just an easy decision?
It was pretty easy. Mean, did start with
we did start with the other approach because
the g cloud command line tool uses that
pattern, for example.
When when we were you know, initially, we
had a tool called Cloud Config, and then
that was changed to KubeConfig.
And then when we're
hitting, you know, problems with the design of
that initial tool
and redoing it, actually, Sam Goads from Box
at the time
stepped in to help us develop kube control.
And,
you know, we compared the two different approaches.
And one big advantage of
kubectl get pods
or actually, you know, kubectl
apply for for instance is,
you can
actually,
apply these commands to multiple different resources and
multiple different resource types more easily if the
verb is first.
Right? So, like, kubectl apply that we just
did there,
you know, operates on arbitrary resource types, and
that's something that we wanted to enable is
these bulk operations.
So the verb first felt more natural and
reinforced the common patterns
across different resource types.
One reason
for the other approach is so people can
use
more easily create unique commands for each different
type of entity,
and we actually
didn't want that. We wanted
the system to be uniform across all different
resources.
And now we, you know, have that
even
more generally with custom resource definitions. But
even with the initial set of we just
had four types originally.
Even with those original four types, you know,
we pretty much wanted the operations to work
the same.
Nice.
Alright. Well, I think we have everything
deployed.
So I'm just gonna go back
here. Maybe
I guess the book because that's the tutorials
we're running through or is there another part
of the guide? Go to the the guides.
Yeah.
So is there anything sorry.
Please, on your call.
Oh, I was just gonna say the the
guide that I was gonna recommend was the
namespace provisioning UI guide.
Alright. Before we kick start that then, I'm
just curious. Like, we have
deployed a whole bunch of stuff to our
cluster. Is there something there's something already there
we can look at, we can play with,
like, play with? What's what's their what's their
There's not a lot interesting there until you
register some repos
and
start developing some packages or importing some packages.
Okay. Well, I mean, one of the things
we can do is we can we can
run kubectl API. I'm getting an echo. Getting
an echo. Yeah. I do
not. I do not.
Right? No. Anyway, kptl
space a p I dash resources, which lists
all the resources registered on any Kubernetes API
server. There should be some with ports. So
if we pipe that to grep porch, I
think that's in the guide for installation as
well. But that shows you some of the
resources that we've we've registered
by setting this up.
Alright.
Alright. Yeah.
I'm getting an echo. I'm getting an echo
from Brian. I'm just gonna mute you for
a moment. I'm not sure what's going on.
Alright.
We have repositories, resource script functions, package revisions,
and package revision resources.
Okay. Let's take a look at this UI.
So this
guide. Sorry.
So in this guide, we will be using
config as data UI to register a blueprint
and
deployment repositories,
create a blueprint from scratch,
and create deployable instance of a kpt package
and to the deploy the package to Kubernetes
cluster.
I mean, is it fair to say we're
going to be using kpt
to deploy a namespace? Is is is that
the the example that we're running through?
Yes.
We're gonna do it using the UI and
porch, but we are you know, this is
the kpt technology. And and together, we call,
I think, the technology
configures data, and kpt is the CLI tool,
which is the server version. So that's why
we have all these different words flying around.
There is one step, by the way, that
we probably need to do, which is to
get that backstage
base URL at the bottom of the ports
UI installation guide. It should tell you how
to do a kubectl port forward
because I assume you don't wanna put it
on the public Internet right now.
So,
I think we did we do this? I
can't remember. But, I mean, we we can
work it out. Right? I mean, I'm assuming
this is like this. And
we can port forward to the service, and
it's just gonna be
The backstage namespace.
Let's see.
Backstage 7007.
Easy. There we go.
Nice.
I was just pulling up the guys to
try to cheat in case it didn't work,
but, yes, you got it right.
Well, see, I like it when we can
take existing knowledge and it just works. But
I'm glad that there was no other steps
required to get to the UI. That's Yeah.
The command for that is in the installation
guide, which we kind of skipped over quickly.
Yeah. I can be quite bad for that.
Feel free just to tell me to stop.
Yeah. There it is.
There we go. Alright.
Let's go back to our namespace
guide. So we have access to the UI.
That's our prerequisite.
We can move on from here. So
the first thing we need to do is
register a blueprint.
What Register
a repo. So you we'll we're gonna need
two
GitHub repos, one for blueprints and one for
deployments.
And you'll need a token
with repo scope.
Okay.
So we need one for blueprints
public.
What was the other one you said? Sorry.
One for deployments.
So
the WYSIWYG aspect is that we fully render
the configuration that we're gonna deploy with GitOps,
back into Git.
Okay. Cool.
And that enables us to just edit it.
We don't always have to regenerate it. We
can just edit it once it's there.
Alright. Okay.
So can we what what is the blueprint
in this context before we go any further?
What do we mean by that?
So the blueprints,
you can think of it as kind of
like a template except that it doesn't have
any markup or
code in it. It's just configuration data. That's
the configuration as data aspect.
It's effectively
kind of a prototype or a model of
the configuration that you
would want to
transform,
customize,
and then deploy.
So it's it's kind of like a customized
base configuration in that respect. Okay. It's
you you can also just think of it
as an example,
but it's just
literal
valid Kubernetes YAML.
Okay.
So to register our repository,
do we do this from the UI?
Should be able to do it from the
UI.
Alright. Let's bring back that for forward.
Go to the config data.
Yeah.
So Backstage is a is a sort of
open source project, I think, initially started by
Spotify, and there's a bunch of
has a bunch of functionality, and it supports
plug ins and and config config as data
is a plug in into it.
Oh, you know what? I'm aware of Backstage,
and I didn't tie the dots when we
called it Backstage earlier. But okay. So you're
this is a plug in for the Spotify
Backstage. Okay.
Yeah. So if you have Backstage already, you
can add this plugin to your own Backstage
instance. This is an image that we created,
you know, just to make it easier to
try out.
Okay. And do I have to log in
with Google? Is that
Yeah. This is a log in, and it's
gonna act as you on the cluster.
Maybe I'll pick a different Google account.
Do I need to set something up?
Sorry. Can you hear what it says?
Can you It says
I need to get full screen.
Or is the org internal client restricted to
users within the organization?
It's the it seems like the
whatever OAuth application this is used in is
restricted to Restricted to Google. Yeah.
Oh, well, that's a bummer. Okay.
We can create a new OAuth
client ID
because I'm guessing that the so we ship
with one that's
it's a bit of a pain to to
go through this process, but,
if you wanna create a you know, if
you wanna log in with Google, you have
to go through and create a client ID.
And we have, bundled one in, but I
guess we have accidentally restricted it to our
organization,
I. E, Google,
which is a bit of a mess up.
And I apologize for create me a Google
account. Right?
I would love Rawkode@Google.com.
I mean, that'd
I'll wait.
Okay. So we could either set up our
own OAuth application
or
is there an alternative?
I'm also worried about whether the authentication is
gonna work to the
if we're not using GKE,
is it going to accept
the ID the credentials?
Brian, what do you think?
Clearly, nobody
no non Googler is driving.
I think that is fine. We can try
the
can try the CLI form of this, which
will be
less good. And maybe we could share the
UI walkthrough, and we can
do it that way. I don't know if
that would work. If you want to share
your screen, I'm happy to do that if
you wanna run through it. But if there's
a way that we can proceed
from the CLI here, we should definitely do
that too.
I'll
I'll let you make the judgment call. You
know what's going Why don't we Brian, what
do think? Should we should we do the
should we go through the CLI instructions, which
I don't think rely on
or they should just work.
There's there's a guide. Let's
do the CLI.
Okay. Then we can do it. If you
wanna share your screen, we can do the
UI demo
afterwards. Exactly. Okay.
So we have this CLI.
What? I'll do without that.
I can type help now.
Okay.
But what we were trying to do is
register a blueprint repository.
So how do we what's the starting point
here?
This is gonna be the alpha commands.
Yeah. And there is there is a guide
which we can
go through if that's easier. I don't know.
Oh, yes. The the name switch version is
CLI. Okay. Cool.
So I've already logged in there. Oh, I
did that too. I love the g h
command line. It just simplifies my life now.
That's great. Although, I I guess you had
to specify public or private, so I'm guessing
we
I'm guessing that's either a new or an
old version of the g h command line
that now requires it. I think it gets
the default to public,
and that's just something that started recently.
Okay. So
we need to
have my user
as Rawkode
and
then
oh, I don't call them blueprint, so let's
fix that. I call it kpt
dash blueprint and
deploy a kpt deployment.
And then
we're gonna clone
both. Okay.
Yeah. So this is a a slightly different
flow from what we were
planning on doing, but it will give you
a better idea of what's going on under
the covers. This is the CLI experience. So
this is the role experience as it were.
And then when, I guess, I screen share
the the UI, we can see better,
like, how we can combine that into a
or build that up into a
nicer user experience that is sort of easier
to just click through and, like, easier to
use.
Cool.
Then we have this cube gen script,
which is taking some parameter.
Yeah. So this this is
just
fixing some words in cube control create,
basically.
We can like I said, you can create
the
or write the resources however you want. We
are just leveraging kubectl create to generate them
in this tutorial.
So what resources do we need to create?
Well, like, you know, namespace
and
RBAC role binding
service account,
things like that.
Okay. I do not have They're pretty pretty
straightforward of these resources.
So
we'll we'll go with the kpten. They have
snippets for a lot of things, but it
looks like I have the RBAC stuff.
So we'll make this executable.
We'll stick it in my path.
That would test that again.
You know, I read a story about hackers
who can listen to your key tape and
when you have a mechanical keyboard, don't work
at what letters you're pressing based on that.
Hello. The noise yeah.
I thought my password is just one two
three four. It's just much safer. Okay? That
way everyone knows it.
Well, that's a good method.
Alright.
Let's create a directory. So this is us
creating our package there. So this is our
base
namespace
package.
And we're gonna use kpt package in it,
and it's gonna write us
files. I'm gonna jump in there and pop
that open.
Maybe we'll change that font size too.
Okay for you? Wanna go a bigger? Yep.
Yep. Okay. That's good.
Alright. Okay. Where's my thing? Okay. So we
have a kept file. We have a read
me, and we have a package context.
We have a tree command.
We'll run that too.
Oh,
it's because I ran into the directory. Yeah.
Cool.
See, I say k for just not following
the gates directly.
I'm sure every time I change something, I'm
like, no. Don't do that.
But okay. So we have a a nice
tree command.
So let's see. Yeah. So the kept file
is contains the metadata for the package. If
you notice, it's in the same format as
Kubernetes resources.
I call that the Kubernetes resource model format.
You know, so right now, it just has
the
minimal amount of metadata.
Yeah. I'm seeing so many tools adopt this
format now that don't even touch Kubernetes or
even deploy to Kubernetes. It seems to just
have become a little bit of a a
standard.
Well, we used it for things like
kube config and the scheduler config and some
other on disk config formats from the beginning.
It makes the tooling
a little bit more homogenous and and easier
to build.
Yep.
And what's this package context dot YAML?
So I don't know that we'll keep this
long term, but what this is doing is
it's actually
just copying
information about the package
into a config map that can be used
as an input to functions,
which we can
talk about more when we're actually getting to
using the functions. But the functions are what
can generate, transform, and validate
the Kubernetes resources that are in the package.
K. And we have some Ruby stuff, but
I think we will stick to the guide.
So
our next thing to do is we're gonna
generate the names of these resources in our
new scripts.
Yeah. So this is basically just doing a
kpt control create and splatting out the YAML
instead of deploying it to the cluster.
And this is just an example of how
you can use
automation tools, command line tools, UIs, whatever,
to generate the YAML. You don't need to
write it by hand.
And because you don't need to
mark it up with, you know, templates or
code or anything,
the tools can also
modify it, edit it after. And that's really
kind of the kept one of the kept
superpowers, I would say, is,
you know, keeping the configuration
in a data format
makes it possible to manipulate it as if
it were,
you know, a live resource, you know, in
the API server, for example.
So if I really wanted to, I could
use Pulumi to render out Kubernetes YAML and
break that in. You you totally could. In
fact, you could probably wrap Pulumi in a
karen function and and both of you can.
Alright.
Well, I think we're gonna save for that
today, but that was something for me to
experiment with over the next couple of days.
That was pretty cool. And one thing I
was actually wondering about is whether we could
use Pulumi in a similar way with the
new YAML support
to generate the YAML with the UI or
however we want and
just deploy it with Pulumi.
We would need to be able to store
the YAML and retrieve the YAML automatically.
I don't know if Pulumi can help with
that or we'd need to build a new
thing for that.
Yeah.
Something for us to
to throw in some ideas for later. There
isn't a way to
get the ABO back, but
maybe in time.
So
we have our namespace.
So this kept package tree, this is this
isn't just like an alias, is it? Is
it a bit more sophisticated, I guess?
It extracts information from the files.
Okay. So we get, like, the description of
what the thing is?
Yeah. It gets the kind and the name.
Okay. That's a simple example c l s.
Of how you can
with with the configuration again just being represented
as YAML or data format, it can extract
information from it. We just started with this
because it seemed useful,
but you could add other information here or
build other kinds of analyses.
Alright.
So next.
Oh, because some scary stuff coming. So we're
gonna run kept functions.
Yeah. I'm not entirely sure what this is
doing. Should I just run it or do
you wanna give me a better context?
So instead of templates
or some other kind of
generator, the kpt model
is
like I said earlier, it's sort of a
twist on the customized approach.
It takes
the the resources from the files,
serializes them into
resource list,
feeds that as inputs to
a sequence of functions
that can operate on the list, and then
writes
the files back to the disk.
So
those functions can
generate resources. They can transform or modify resources.
They can validate resources.
So it's we're using the
YAML representation as kind of a intermediate representation
for operating on it.
When we do this through
Porch, when we can show show the UI,
what it's doing is
extracting that actually out of git,
transforming it, and putting it back into git.
So actually one it's not in the guide,
one thing you can do here is just
kpt function source,
function abbreviated source all spelled out.
Yeah.
So this is the format that it's feeding
to the functions.
And, you know, it is a list of
the resources including the kpt file that are
in the package
with some additional metadata so that it can
write them back into the same place, like,
you know, keeping track of the file path
names, for example.
Okay.
So but I just so I'm I make
sure I understand this. Right? So we're running
a kept function,
and we're gonna evaluate this as a mutate
or that makes sense. I'm gonna scuff over
keywords. I'm not sure right now. But the
image is really you're setting the function. Right?
So the all these functions are container images
that have that they can put and give
us output,
and then we provide the config.
So this is called set namespace. So I'm
assuming if I run this on, like, a
deployment, it would add the namespace from our
kept context. Is that
close?
I see a little bit of a nod.
It's actually take it's taking the
name of the namespace from that config map.
So if you scroll to the right,
that package context dot yaml is that config
map you were asking about earlier Mhmm. That
had
a field that said name
example right there is yeah.
So it's taking that value and using that
as the name of the namespace. So what
we're doing right now is we're creating a
blueprint. So a blueprint is just a package
that is intended to be used as a
base,
not to be deployed directly.
The reason we're running this function
is as a test
of the function effectively.
Because
when we like, customize generates variance from bases.
When we create the deployment, we will do
that similarly using this function.
So
this the purpose of this command is just
to test that the function does what we
expect.
Okay. What's the dash dash keywords namespace?
I'm not sure how this applies in this
context.
I don't think we actually need that. Alright.
Cool. Yeah. I I think it's I think
it's for autocomplete.
Oh, it says that up right above.
If you were using autocomplete,
it could help you discover
the image
if you pass that. Ah, alright. Okay. So
this kinda narrows down the scoping. Yeah.
The set namespace is
in our function catalog, and it has metadata
attached. We don't have that many functions right
now, so you can browse them all.
If in the UI,
we do string matching. So if you start
typing name,
this function will come up.
Through the CLI,
yeah, we rely on auto completion and need
a different way to provide the hint.
Okay. Got it. So I So yeah.
Let's pull in a container image.
I'll assume they're pretty small. No values have
changed.
Are we m one Mac issue, or can
we just ignore that?
We are definitely having an m one Mac
issue. I'm not entirely sure why it's a
warning.
Let's see if it actually did it. Whether
that's just a warning or that's an error
error. I mean, it I'm a little confused.
Ran.
Did it? It ran. Yeah. It it says
all these pieces are already the sample. Yeah.
So Alright. Moving on. So the next function
is
So this is just repeating the same thing,
but what it's gonna do is append this
function to the kept file.
So whenever
people wanna create a variant,
we can set this up to run the
function automatically.
Okay. And now we have our mutators listed.
Okay. Things are starting to click my head
now. I'm starting to Yeah. So I'll just
point out that that automatically modified the kpt
file.
So that's a general pattern in kpt as
it functions,
tools,
interfaces
can actually just modify
all the resources including the kpt file in
order to automate things and make it simpler.
Okay. Got it.
So that's now showing us that, and then
we can do a function
render.
So what the function render does is it
runs the functions that are in the kpt
file.
So we just added that function to the
kpt file. So this is basically just testing
that it worked.
Okay.
And the general pattern that we're using, you
can think of those functions
in
one way kind of like Kubernetes and Mesh
control,
but applied to your package.
So after we make any change, we probably
just wanna rerun
those functions. For example, if we added a
resource to the package,
we would wanna set the namespace.
So we would just rerun kpt function render.
Okay. So kpt function render runs everything that's
at the bottom of the kpt file as
the pipeline?
Yeah. Exactly. Okay. And we're modifying the resources
in place. So this is one big difference
with kpt compared to kustomize is kustomize will
take the base configuration, apply some transformations and
patches, and splat out the configuration to somewhere
else, like the standard out,
for example, so you can pipe it to
kptrl apply or apply it with a GitOps
tool.
Here, we are actually modifying the resources in
place.
And what that enables is we can decouple
the the generation and the transformation in time.
So, you know, we can
we just generated a namespace,
and we transformed the kpt file by adding
the set namespace function to it.
We don't have to do that every time
we wanna use this blueprint in the future.
It's gonna be there. It's gonna be stored
there in GETs, and we can do additional
transformations later. We don't have to, like, write
a thousand step pipeline to do all the
changes that we've ever done in the history
of making changes.
Okay. It's taking advantage of the fact that
the contents are declarative.
Just saying, like, it doesn't matter how
you got to this point.
This is the
desired
state of of what you want it to
be.
Yeah. Yeah. I definitely I get that. That
makes sense to me.
So it looks like we got another resource
to Jen next. So that's the Yeah. So
this one's a little bit more interesting than
namespace. Namespace is pretty short. It's not that
hard to write from scratch.
Row binding is a little bit longer.
Yep. There we go.
Oh, we are giving away,
an app admin role to the group here.
Okay.
We've already catered it.
We're going to
okay. So this is
Yeah. I mean, these are just these are
just examples. And what we're trying to do
is, essentially,
if you look at the email address, I
think it was, like, example.admin@bigco.com.
And the point is that we would imagine
that we're doing a scenario where each group
each namespace would be owned by a different
group. And so we wanna replace in particular
that example bit before the dot admin. And
so the idea is, you know, you would
you would create a group of administrator. When
you're creating a namespace, you wanna create a
a group of people that are able to
administer it, and each one of those gets
their own group. But now the problem is
if we don't have templating,
how are we going to replace that example
in the very bottom line there, the example
dot admin? Because it's not that it's not
a simple value substitution anymore. It's, like, just
a bit before the dot. So
that's the challenge that we're gonna solve with
functions.
Yeah. As you started talking, I I realized
that some of this is also covered in
your blurb that I've just been skipping by
and scrolling through. Kinda just blah blah blah.
It's fine. Copy the command. So thank you
for providing that extra context.
Yeah. So you could write a function to
this specific thing. If it's gonna be common,
that may be a better way that would
involve less configuration.
This is the apply replacements transform from customize
packaged in a function that we can use
and kept.
Okay.
And it's it's basically doing a patch where
the the it can take the input
of the patch from a specified
location.
Okay. That makes sense.
Yeah. Okay. Got it.
So now we can run
this. So this is, yes, gonna add this
function to the kpt file.
And from that point, whenever we need to
run all of these transformations, it's just the
kpt function render.
Exactly.
Okay. I can see the workflow here. I
can see how you you kind of you
make the change. It gets persisted to the
kpt file.
And then when someone else checks us out,
they're just running the render function. I'm assuming
people can reuse these packages and provide their
own context. Is that kinda where we're moving
forward to here?
Yeah. Exactly. Okay. Cool.
Yeah. We actually need to check-in this blueprint
in order to make it,
you know, usable as a deployment.
But that that'll be coming up in the
tutorial, presumably.
Alright.
Will we skip the quota that you wanna
run through? Sorry. You can skip the quota.
K.
So cut up a directory,
add the directory.
I don't think I'm in
should I move this to the right location?
Was this supposed to be inside my blueprints?
Yeah. That'd be good. Yes.
Alright. So now if I oh, I don't
need to do it.
Take that off. So we can do add
and just over tagging it to alright. Okay.
So the the purpose of the tag is
to mark it as a particular version or
revision.
Alright.
And that that enables us to do things
like discover that there's a new version and
suggest an upgrade, things like that. Yeah. So
now our our package is in this blueprints
repository that we created. I'm assuming as we
move over to this deployment repository, we're gonna
consume this package
in some way and
alright. K.
So we're gonna go to kpt deployments.
And from here, we're gonna run a kept
package get.
And I'm pretty sure I still have that
environment variable kicking around.
Yeah.
And that's close it. So I'm assuming
yeah. That's our directory.
Cool.
But does that mean that I can met
my blueprints with my deployments?
Are those set up as sub modules or
something like that? Like, how does that work?
You
do commit your blueprints.
You also,
like, I think one of the ideas here
is that, yes, you do,
commit your deployments as well. Brian can get
into the the logic there, but the,
what the the theory there, there's a strong
theory behind it. Mean, it's essentially, it means
you can really understand what's gonna happen at
all times when it actually gets to your
cluster.
It also means
that you can just
we you have base configuration
from the blueprint.
You don't have to
modify the blueprint or transform the blueprint with
functions with kpt function render. You can also
just edit
the deployment
directly.
And that's effectively
auto generates a
patch
on top of the blueprint is one way
to think about it,
except that you can just edit. You don't
have to actually think about how to express
the patch.
You can just edit.
Okay.
So
Alright. Let's see what's going on here then.
we took that.
Then So just so you do a kept
function render.
Your
It was updated now, our namespace example.
So I'm assuming
Yeah. I think the the important thing to
remember is when you created your blueprint,
your
base package, your namespace name was example. Here
you have, instantiated
an instance of that package into a directory
called back end. That was the name you
gave it.
And,
the name here is an important concept that,
with those functions you copied into or assigned
to the name of the namespace, which is
why the name of the namespace is now
back end. If you were to create another
one called back end two and hit function
render, it would be called back end two.
So you can create as many instances you
want,
and the the functions run and they
enforce the invariants that you as the author
of that package blueprint defined. So the invariants
you've defined are that the namespace should be
called the same as the package name and
that the group should be
the
packagename.admin@bigco.com.
So if we have a look at the
role binding, it should hopefully have back end
dot admin.
Doesn't it? Yeah.
So this is a simple example illustrating what
I call the variant constructor pattern where, you
know, a common thing is you just wanna
create multiple
different variants of the same blueprint.
You might want in this case, you know,
we're creating multiple namespaces for multiple teams or
something, but,
you know, you could also have dev and
prod environments, things like that.
So other inputs may be needed to fully
specialize
the blueprint for your particular scenario.
In this case, no other inputs are needed
other than just the back conditioning. We're just
leveraging that to generate an identity for each
variant.
Additional hand editing or
automated transformations
could also be done to the deployment.
But here, they're not really necessary. So this
is, like, the simplest possible case where all
you have to just do is say what
you want the name and the namespace to
be and everything is
generated automatically for you. You don't have to
touch anything.
Okay. I'm I'm curious. Are these kept merge
comments?
How the patches work? Are these important? Or
are these
Yeah.
So if we change the blueprints
after do after doing this, after creating the
deployment,
and we wanted to pick
up that change in the deployment,
then we would do a kept package updates
to pull in the changes
from the blueprint.
And that
kept merge
comment
keeps track of the mapping
between the customized deployment and the original blueprint.
Okay. So if I update in
the
kept blueprint and change the email address in
big code dot com to
extra large code dot com and tag that
again, we would be able to pull through
and update that even though we've already done
some
changes? We would. We probably wouldn't
want that to necessarily stomp
what was in here. So
in different scenarios, might want different merge
strategies.
That's something we're working on right now.
But I the way I think of the
blueprint is that it provides defaults.
Oh,
so, you know, if we didn't actually change
from the defaults in the deployment, we probably
would wanna pick up the change. On the
other hand, if we didn't edit and overwrote
it, we probably wouldn't wanna pick it up.
Right? Like, that's how customize would work.
Looking I look at a bunch of helm
charts and when people add new
fields or change things,
they conditionalize them so that existing
deployments of the chart don't actually pick up
those changes.
So clearly, a lot of people
don't want
new behaviors picked up necessarily from a base
deployment.
So
that's something that we're still
working out as to what behaviors, you know,
people
would expect or would want for different scenarios.
Cool. But but I but I wouldn't like,
the workflow you described is is the workflow
that that we enable. Right? You create the
instance of the package. You can edit it
manually, and you can still take in changes
from upstream as that upstream package evolves. So
if there's a new version of
MySQL,
you can go and get that new package,
and and it will merge in.
The the undefined or the under defined behavior
that we're trying to
define better is what happens when you change
a field, when you've both changed a field,
there's an overlap, a git conflict, or what
you know, a conflict in editing, and that's,
I think, where we are working through still.
But when you make the majority of changes,
you can just make your local changes and
pull in upstream changes
as you as you want or do expect
to.
Alright.
I was about to ask a question there,
but I see it's the next heading. So
I'm gonna go ahead and just commit
and push this. Because I was like, okay.
Do we just give control, apply this now,
or do we use config sync? I think
that's what I had in school. Right? So
that's yeah. That's pushed.
If I recall, we're gonna use kept live,
which is more like a
a more advanced version of kubectl
apply,
but
you can also do it using config sync.
I think in the UI, we go through
it using,
like, a GitOps tool and config sync in
that case. I think in the CLI demonstration,
we're directly applying it. It's sort of the
easier way to get going and doesn't require
config sync. We've already installed config sync, so
you could also do it that way. But
Alright.
Well, it looks like we have some sort
of resource script thing created
with the namespace for the project,
and then we just do a
kpt live apply
back end.
It worked. That's it. Right? One of the
yeah. One of the cool things about kpt
live apply is it, it checks the I
believe it checks the status of this. So
you can see, you know, pending and successful.
There's a,
so it can do things like tell you
if your deployment actually apply actually
reached a stable state at the you know,
when ready as it were. Like, kubectl, we
have to explicitly wait.
Alright.
So I wanna make sure that I understand
this right. Kptlive is different from config sync.
These are two different ways of applying the
configuration to the cluster.
They are. They they share code, they're actually,
they're they're similar in in logic.
But, yes, kept live is the CLI form.
Config Sync is the server form.
Regardless,
what we're doing is we're reading from files,
fully hydrated, like, ready to apply files and
applying them to the cluster.
So you could use kpt live. You can
use kptly apply. You can use config sync.
You can use any
GitOps style tool that you
want to use or or or are already
using
Okay. Or already using. So I would suggest
that we
actually run through the UI if Justin can
share
that, just so can do that before we
run out of time.
Yeah. Push the scary button.
Let's see.
I'm gonna get let's see. Let me move
I will apologies if I look to the
side, but otherwise, we'll get the, you know,
never ending.
I think I am sharing
the
configuration.
Very professional setting up a quick
Oh, here we are.
It even looks a little bit like me
in in silhouette.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay. So this is the configuration as data,
UI. I have,
logged in, and let me just check that
it's yeah. Okay. Good. So my port forward
is still working. I was a little worried.
I might have timed out. So we've basically
gone through the first couple of steps here
of of the
configuration
and,
very similar we we've done very similar things
to what you've done in the CLI. So
I have
defined my own kept deployment
repo and my own kept blueprints repo. They're
They're actually linked to my GitHub, not yours.
We could try registering yours in a minute,
but I
don't know how we wanna drive this, whether
it's
shall I go through
I mean, I've gone through this or there's
already a blueprint or a couple of blueprints
that I've created, but we can create another
one from scratch. That's that's what the guide
Why
don't you browse the base in s blueprint?
Okay. Perfect. So this is one that I've
created from scratch following the guide
using
the using the UI here.
And
we have a very similar set of files
to the files that you created using the
CLI. So we have the kpt file,
a namespace.
We have the config map that was created
using init. We have the apply replacements that
you also created, which updates the role binding,
and you can see that that there.
We did we did create the resource quota
that we skipped over, and here's, like, a
role binding. And,
why don't I try
I wanted to start creating a new one
so we can see some of the UI
that that is able to be done here.
I'm gonna create it from scratch. We'll call
it Justin two.
We're adjusting one earlier. So this is the
equivalent of kpt
package in it. I can create it,
And then write the kept file and config
map. And if I want to
start adding resources, then I can do that.
So I think first thing we added was
a a namespace and,
I don't know, x and s. This is
this is the blueprints. Right? So I think
you do want example there.
Okay.
And
let's see.
I mean, we can go through and we
can add some more. So let's add a,
like, let's add a role binding,
and you can see that we get a
a a very sophisticated,
or a purpose built UI for role bindings.
So, like, we call it app admin,
and,
we had a role reference
to a cluster role named, I assume, app
admin.
And we had a subject
binding to a group
named,
if I recall, example.admin@bigco.com.
And so I can
show show the YAML view, which is what
we did before, and save it and
through the UI I'm editing.
Is this a bit small? I apologize. So
is this pushing us to get repository or
somewhere else at the moment, or is it
like, where does the state live?
We are working through Porch in this instance.
The configuration as data UI is talking to
Porch,
and it is, in fact, backed by a
Git repository. And this particular Git repository is
the kpt Blueprints repository,
which is backed by github.com/bitmsb/blueprints.
What did I do wrong? Oh, I'm not
logged into GitHub.
Scary.
Alright.
Let me I think I'm sharing my screen.
I don't think that
which is right here. And so,
there is somewhere a draft where we're working
on it. You can see that we're pushing
to it recently.
But as we go through, we we are
working with the git repository here.
K. Porch makes a bit more sense in
my head now. I understand what it's actually
doing. It's a server side component that's backing
this UI that is handling. But right now,
we just didn't get but you mentioned earlier
that that could be an OCIR effect at
some point as well. It it can be
OCI,
registries as repositories as well. And, yeah, that
that support is ongoing, but, yes, it it
works as well today.
It's a little easier for some people.
It's easier for others, and so we support
both. Awesome. Got it.
And we're we're defining exactly the same resources
that you were defining on the command line,
just in a sort of slightly easier to
use
user interface.
It's particularly easier to use when you're, like,
instantiating packages. So I don't know if should
I just save this and we can continue?
Is that I have one I made earlier,
or do wanna keep going through, Brian?
Well, just pull up the kpt file and
show adding a function, I guess. Oh, perfect.
Yeah. Great.
So
if I wanted to add a mutator, let's
add the replacements.
So, like, before we added apply replacements,
here, we can see all the versions that
are available. There's only one.
And
I'm gonna need to create the apply replacements
resource yet. You're right. I will do that.
I need to create an apply replacements resource
to define
the
the the configuration.
Update role
update role finding. Typing under pressure is hard.
I have empathy for you for doing this
earlier. Thank you for driving it earlier.
ConfigMap,
the sources. You see you see it's actually
it's listed all the objects in the
in the package.
And once I pick one, it actually shows
me the various paths available with the actual
values from the package right now. So it's
it's
a purpose built UI
per component
or per kind that enables us to give,
like, a really great user experience or at
least a better user experience.
Yeah. So this shows, you know, just kind
of a proof of concept of something you
can do when you have the UIs.
You know, it provides that it's kind of
like auto completion, but it provides, you know,
assistance in picking the right values. Yep.
I've gone through this process a bunch of
times, and I do have to say it's
less error prone than doing it by hand.
So
Challenge accepted, Brian.
So there we go. So I I've I've
gone back into the kpt file and done
up I've now bound to the apply replacements
function to the configuration for it. I can
add another mutator, I guess, to
Set namespace.
Yeah. Let's do that. I think add
so
namespace, and it will find set namespace. There's
the latest version, which I think we knew
before. And I think for this one, I
need the config map. So now I can
save it.
I think that's enough. Right?
Yep. We could do a resource quota quickly.
Should we do the resource quota thing as
we skipped that last time? No? We should
just we're almost out of time.
Oh, sorry. Okay. I will save the package.
I will propose the package, which is the
equivalent of doing a pull request.
Someone else comes in because I never approve
my own pull requests,
and
approves the package.
And
then
you can see And so one thing we
didn't we didn't really show is that hide
comparison. You can actually diff with
I we're creating a blueprint there, so there's
nothing to diff with. But
you can actually review this
and view the resources without looking at YAML,
without
dealing with the Git provider.
You can do it all in the context
of the UI if you want.
Nice.
And I I I just showed that, like,
on GitHub, you've you can see that that
package Justin two was just approved
mere seconds ago and is now on the
main branch.
So it's it's there and ready to go.
And
there are
two types of repositories. There are blueprint repositories
where, you know, this package now exists in
the published state
version one. So, you know, it's done all
the tagging and all that for you.
And there are deployment repositories.
And,
here, we have the deployment repository that I
registered
in the configures data UI.
I have previously created some some packages, but
I can also instantiate
instantiate the blueprints just as you did,
from here. And we can actually drive it
from here. So if I do this, I
can say deploy.
I wanna go to the deployment. I will
call it
Rawkode
B.
Okay.
Yep.
And
so
we're now creating
an instance of
that package
or that blueprint in the deployment repository.
We've called it Rawkode Justin SB.
I will it's still under draft form of
Rawkode seven. Look look at the, like, role
binding, for example.
Ah, thank you. What you expect.
And
so it did create
the,
rule code just in SP just to sort
of kept it on the command line. It
it put that in. It changed the namespace,
of course, to rule code just in SP,
the name of the package.
So
I can now propose
this.
I can approve it, and I think it
will actually
so I've approved it. So now if I
go and look at github at kept
deployments,
it will now be,
what did I do wrong?
Do you call it just deployments? Is it
kept deployment? Deployments. I just yeah. Just to
confuse myself, I did not. Thank you. And
so there it is. Again, seventeen seconds ago,
I guess it takes me seventeen seconds to
get to GitHub.
And then
if I create sync, it will actually, like,
do it straight. It will create the config
sync, from here as well. So, you know,
this is what you do with kpt, live
apply from the command line. Here, we have
a config sync integration. There could be other
integrations, but is a config sync integration, and
it will go and apply it to the
cluster.
So that'll take a couple of seconds, and
it will shortly appear on the I think
on the same cluster it's it's bound to.
So
there we are. Yeah. So that way in
the future,
when any change is approved, it will automatically
get,
synced to the cluster.
Alright.
Anything else you want to show in the
UI before I
If we wanna try to break one more
thing, I was gonna think it might be
fun to let me show the registration of
of repository. So let's try to register the
one that you created earlier,
which I think is public. So It is?
Yep.
But does do read only repos actually work?
Well, I was thinking it would be fun
to demonstrate how we can
even if a third party,
like David, created the, the blueprint, I can
consume them
myself. So
oh, well, I can call it the same
thing. Alright.
Let's try that again. But, yes,
see.
I didn't see where I could specify a
name. Well, perhaps that's a slight bummer. Okay.
We
need to be able to specify that oh,
there it is. Kpt. There you go. Roll
code.
Thanks.
Thank you. Blueprint.
The wonders of an ad hoc demo.
Exactly. Now it's a real one. I mess
it up. I mess up everything.
And so now we have another Blueprint repository
registered.
So, you know, I'm consuming from an upstream
expert that has created a base namespace package
for me. And so now I can just
go and instantiate this blueprint,
myself if I wanted to or deploy this
namespace myself if I wanted to.
So I'll go to deployments,
Click in. Add a deployment
of
I think you have your own repo as
the registered
upstream. Upstream.
Yes. Okay. So
there might be some tweaking to be done
there, but I can, create,
in theory, I can create one from your
blueprints also, and we'll make that a little
bit easier, a little bit smoother. I think
the UI is bound to that particular one
right now. But, yeah, so here we can,
you know, create packages, edit them,
push changes,
create deployments from those, store those in gits
and version them as well.
So we actually
I don't know if you can show the
revisions on one of the package.
You can
undo by restoring a previous revision.
So that's something that you can't
as easily do
revisions. The revisions tab.
I I don't have I I only have
one revision of everything. So I'm just creating
a second. That's fine.
But, yeah, you can you know, this UI
is pretty nascent. It's it's basically a proof
of concept, but
you can interact
with the configuration all through the UI without
necessarily touching YAML or touching git or the
git provider pull requests,
all that. So it actually saves
dozens of steps for common operations.
So I think it's pretty
promising. And, like, especially for people who aren't
as familiar with,
you know, say, Git push mechanics or,
you know, the exact formatting of Kubernetes deployment
YAML, things like that.
Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. I'm gonna sorry.
Anything else there?
I was just gonna say, like, we were
able to, like, create that
that instance of the of the package and
deploy it without, you know, touching the command
line. So it is certainly easier if you
if I hadn't had if I hadn't showed
you editing the package or creating the package
first, that would have been a very simple
experience of just adding the deployment.
Nice.
Alright. I'm gonna pop this back over to
our, like, facie mode. There we go.
So that was really cool. I really like
a lot of what I'm seeing here. I'm
curious. Like
I mean, I don't wanna say anything bad
about Helm. Right? But I I don't find
it personally an enjoyable experience for consuming third
party software and applications. Like, install in MariaDB
and Postgres, MongoDB, all these other tools.
And I'm sitting here going, why don't we
have blueprints for all of this and consume
them for kpt? Like, this model,
I've been able to have the base that
the experts produce and then me tailoring it
to the with I need through defining pipelines
of functions in a kpt file. And we
don't do it today, but I'm assuming I
really easily write and publish my own function
to make any random
changes that weren't already covered by the the
kpt library. So it feels like we have
a really good end to end flow for
tweaking and tailoring
base manifest for software and deployment to our
clusters that doesn't require help. Like, I'm not
a fan of of Go templates. I never
remember the syntax. I always have to Google
how to do loops and ranges and all
these other things. Like, this just feels like
a nicer approach and I'd like to think
and hope that we can get to a
point where we have something better than hell.
But I think kpt is a pretty good
and strong contender based on what I've seen.
Like,
now I'll throw that back at you. I
mean, is that do you see a world,
and is this why you're working on kpt?
Like, do you feel it can replace helm
to a certain degree and provide us a
better ecosystem for shipping third party software?
And then we can always pull it back
and talk about first party software. But right
now, I see a big market for third
party, and I'm curious if you agree.
I
think first party is
kept as a lot more ready for. I
think third party is an obvious target because
those templates tend to be more complex.
You know, they basically
use what I call the construct constructor pattern.
They parameterize every possible attributes
of the resources that they contain. Yeah. And
kpt enables a model where that's not necessary.
Like,
you know, just because somebody might want to
change
node selector or tolerations or some, you know,
obscure field of the
Kubernetes deployment API,
doesn't mean it has to be in the
base configuration.
The way kpt can scale across multiple packages
is by
creating logic that's reusable across all packages containing
the same resource types.
So for for example, the backstage UI, if
we add,
the deployment resource, the service resource, ingress gateway,
you know, application oriented resources,
then we can use that to author
blueprints
that contain those resources
pretty easily. And then, you know, we will
need a complimentary set of functions that perform
common transformations to those resources.
And once we have that in the catalog,
then we can create this kind of low
code experience where,
you know, over time, people will have to
write fewer and fewer functions from scratch,
to do these things. You know, you can
automatically
update images, for example, is a super common
one. So we do actually have a function
for that
because it's something people commonly wanna do in
in CICD,
for instance.
And we can actually write that change back
to get
and there are some image updaters that can
do that already for flux and ArgoCD. Mhmm.
But we can change arbitrary fields in those
resources with a similar level of automation.
Yeah. This is a common frustration I see.
I mean, especially talking to people that are
adopting GitOps,
you know, is that ingress is a a
example and and horizontal pod autoscalers. These are
things that need to be significantly tweaked
from one environment to another. Like, the domain
name you use for your ingress is very
different in staging as it goes from prod,
I would hope. Your HPA rules are not
as aggressive in staging as they might be
in prod.
And, yeah, right now, it's a lot of
value files and helms and template to do
that. But actually,
this feels nicer. This feels like something that
also happens
because here's the other way. If people aren't
doing this through templating, they're doing it through
mutating admission. And the problem with mutating admission
is you don't know what's broken until you
apply it to the cluster.
And that's Yeah. Here we can do predeployment
validation, review, and approval,
any of those types
of
kind of change control
processes that you wanna apply before you deploy.
Like I said, after deployment, you can also
do
undo by reverting to a previous revision if
you need to, but you can still get
that
WYSIWYG experience if you want it or, you
know, automate it as much as you want.
So we barely
start to scratch the surface on this, but
since we make all the packages available through
an API,
we can actually write automation to bulk update
packages, for example. Yeah.
So that's something that I'm personally pretty excited
about.
You know, there's lots of work to do,
but
also a lot of things that weren't possible
before where you'd have to manually,
you know, check out and update a hundred
packages to,
you know, go
make some change across all of them. Like,
what if you wanna change the
API version of some objects in all your
packages? That's just super painful right now.
But we can actually,
you know, just write
a simple script to do it with kpt
and just extract the package contents,
make the change. You can even run set
on it and and write it back, and
it takes care of all the get mechanics
for you. You mean I I don't have
to have four f conditions to check for
the last 17 major versions of Kubernetes and
inject n v one v one alpha one
or know?
It's it's this has to get to be
true. But as I say, I really like
what I'm seeing, and I don't wanna keep
this too much more because this is roughly
where we said we would end in 10.
So I'll just say, is there anything else
that you you wanna share with the audience
before we finish? If you wanna maybe give
thirty second or a minute overview on what's
coming next, like, are you just working on
what your priorities,
And then we'll we'll finish up with today.
Well, we are working you know, this example
was a namespace
provisioning example. That's something I often see UIs
used for. Most Kubernetes platforms have some kind
of UI for, you know, creating namespaces or
projects or workspaces or whatever they call them.
So we wanted to show that you could
do that through UI and also get all
the same benefits of
GitOps and
kind of configuration as code but without the
code,
really. I mean, there is code that's in
the functions, but hopefully, you know, someone else
wrote those functions and you don't have to,
for every single package you have. So but
we are focused on, you know, you mentioned
home charts. Definitely,
the first thing people
wanna do with Kubernetes is deploy applications. So
we're we're working on making the application,
configuration experience easier. That's, I'd say, the next
big priority that we're working on. So adding
those resources to the backstage UI,
creating
bigger portfolio of functions that people will commonly
need,
creating some examples so people can see, you
know, how to actually express blueprints in kept
for applications.
There are some
tricky problems that we need to figure out.
You know, it's a very novel approach,
so, you know, not everything is is figured
out. But,
you know, the if you're interested in contributing,
there's
lots of interesting
things to do. So, you know, definitely contributors
are welcome.
Yeah. I just I just wanna I just
wanna add, like, this is early. Sorry. I'm
like, this is early and, like, we want
the we is, like, all of us. Like,
if you're interested in this space, like, we
don't intend to build this and sort of
build it ourselves. Like, we need to hear
what problems you are experiencing when you try
to use these things or why
do you find Helm annoying and why do
you find Helm great and what should we
copy and what should we try to improve,
you know, all these sorts of things. And
so please join us on the kpt channel
on the Kubernetes Slack and
github.com/googlecontainertools/kpt,
and
we look forward to discussing this and and
hopefully building it with you.
And is that true that anyone that can
contribute to PR gets the Google email address
so they can use the UI?
That's up to Brian. We will go off
and fix that.
But but actually, you know, I am interested
also in hearing, you know, whether
this makes sense, how do you think about
it,
because it's
like I said, on one hand, it's familiar.
It works has the same kind of experience
as imperative tools,
imperative UIs, ELIs,
that kind of thing, except it is actually
declarative,
and automated under the hood.
So
we're still kind of
trying to figure out
the best way of explaining it. So
the
you know, to kinda communicate the power of
what it can do, but hopefully, will also
just become more obvious over time as we
build out the the functionality to demonstrate the
potential.
Awesome. Well, I encourage people to start playing
with it, jump into GitHub, start looking for
issues, PRs, get involved. It's a really interesting,
exciting, early stage project, and I think those
are the best ones because people can bring
their knowledge, their expertise, and share that with
you and hopefully shape
what is the the future of Kubernetes deployment.
Very exciting thing. Yeah. Yeah. We definitely need
that. You know, people who have all the
paper cuts from doing it all the other
a hundred different ways.
Alright. Well, thank you so much for your
time, both of you.
It's been a really interesting look, and thank
you for driving a very ad hoc demo
as well, Justin. I really appreciate you just
kind of walking us through that as well.
And Thank you so much. This was fun.
I'll let you both get back to your
day. Have a good one. I'll speak to
you both soon, Anna.
Thanks for having us on. Cheers. Bye. Thank
you. Bye.